- [Narrator] Coverage of the
ongoing conflict in Israel
has featured recurring images like this.
Missiles streaming across the
sky and exploding mid-air.
(explosion popping)
These are missiles from Israel's
Iron Dome missile defense system,
a land-based system that
intercepts and destroys
short-range rockets and mortars.
(missile whooshing)
It has become a bedrock
of the country's defense
since its introduction in 2011,
and in the current round of hostilities,
Israel's military said the system
has intercepted more than 200
of the more than 1,000 rockets
fired towards Israel as of May 12th.
Here's how the complex detection
and interception system works.
The system is powered by
missile defense batteries,
each containing three main components.
These batteries can defend
across short-range rocket
and mortar attacks within
almost 45 miles of the battery.
They are also mobile,
so they can be moved to
where they are needed.
First, a radar unit
detects an incoming rocket
and relays information about
its speed and trajectory
to the battery's control center.
The control center's computers calculate
if the rocket is going
to hit populated areas.
If it is, a missile is
fired from the launcher.
Each launcher contains
20 interceptor missiles.
Each receives constant guidance updates
from the control center
and its internal radar.
The missile destroys the incoming rocket
by exploding near it.
The goal is to do this far
away from populated areas,
minimizing damage on the ground.
The defense system has
intercepted over 2,400 rockets
bound for civilian areas
since its launch in 2011
according to an Israeli
military spokesperson.
During a conflict in 2012,
the Iron Dome knocked down 421 rockets
launched from Gaza and
bound for Israeli cities
before a November ceasefire,
and during the 2014 war in Gaza,
it intercepted 700 rockets fired
by Islamist movement Hamas,
a 90% success rate that
effectively blunted
the Palestinian group's aerial threat.
The United States has provided
hundreds of millions of dollars
and funding for the system
and has also bought and is testing
two Iron Dome batteries of its own,
and Israel has expanded the defense system
by installing missile batteries on ships,
and the system is in the
midst of being upgraded
to combat the threat
posed by unmanned drones.
As the current conflict continues,
so will the use of the Iron Dome.